um I was working I was doing post on a
film called Henry's crime I was in
Technicolor in New York and Chris
connealy the director and writer was the
post supervisor
he had also done a directiy documentary
before and I was an actor and kind of I
was a producer on it to a certain extent
and we were in the DI process and we
were in the moment where we were doing
and this is were side by side came up we
were doing the moment where they've
color corrected it digitally and then
they're matching the photochemical to
the digital image and we had behind us
in the back we had a colorist and a
timer and at the same time Malcolm Van
Ville the director was talking about how
he'd been working digitally in
commercials and Paul Cameron the
cinematographer was showing me images on
a DSLR for a commercial that he had shot
in to think this is what he had used and
I was talking to Charlie Hertzfeld who
was you know the head of motion pictures
and and at Technicolor to New York and
he was telling me how his business was
changing and I was sitting there and
Chris and I were like talking and and I
was just looking around and I had this
kind of aha moment which was it's film I
I remember just going this is all going
away film is going away because I was
just feeling the impact of how much it
was becoming digital and to me the
digital camera was the last piece and so
I I wanted to you know I asked Chris if
he wanted to go on this kind of
expedition to find out what was going on
and that turned into side by side and
Chris you know being in the post he and
I were side by side because you know we
started in the documentary it was like
well what are we losing and Chris was
like well what are we gaining and where
did we come from and where are we now
and where could this be going
and so for me it was yeah I was I was
the what are we losing film the texture
of film the materiality of it the look
of it working with it
artisans and craftspeople who work with
it and everything I was directed to
utilizing capitalizing on this medium
and I think it goes into just the idea
of the image being digitized to how
we're dealing with exhibition and
distribution and then in in in the
documentary we're talking earlier when
you when we're speaking about well how
is this affecting it's the director and
you know a lot of the focus here is to
cinematographer the keeper of the image
and how that image is now have it being
impacted that so many steps of the way
to where the cinematographer is kind of
like catching up to the image in the
early days fighting for the image you
know the colourists had their moment of
like eye color you know which though on
the other hand brought great opportunity
and flexibility and specificity and you
know now you can you know the the way
that you can treat a color of a film now
it's not films are going in a bath and
like everything changes you know you be
so specific on what you want to do with
your image it was it was fun in the
sense of as we started this journey
really from technical in New York and
then we went to camera image camera Maj
in Poland and kind of assaulted
bum-rushed
that festival really lovely people there
and so we started with the
cinematographers and as we as we kind of
as the word kind of got on the street it
was like oh yeah we've heard of you oh
yeah we heard oh we go you talked to
that and it started to really help us in
a sense that you know we were getting a
reputation of being thorough good and
just you know trying to talk to everyone
know this is fantastic I mean the big
screen is is in the sound in the place
and you know the communal experience is
you know it's where I come from but you
know I still enjoy it I try to separate
from nostalgia and just say well what is
it really
and it's fantastic you know Chris Nolan
he speaks about it not um it didn't make
the documentary but he speaks about the
human face and just somehow the the size
and the intimacy and and what that can
be in the way that's cinema you know the
way film treats the human face but we're
not I mean I don't think that's going to
go away it's if anything there's more
and more ways to see art storytelling so
I don't you know in digital projectors
and and DCP and you know read Jim
Jannard you know they're coming up with
other you know if anything the way to
see images large is going to get cheaper
and better quality actually it just
won't be enough might be in your garden
the concepts that are introduced here
are like a beginning as opposed to an
end to me you know in the sense of
Howard how are we going to tell our
stories how are we gonna watch our
stories who's going to make them and how
are they going to make them I think is a
really lovely beginning and an eternity
is film dead that's the one thing that I
don't know that you know it's going to
be like well what happened